à leur arrivée prise de température
obligatoire et distribution d'un kit
sanitaire en deuxième masque pour
l'après midi un petit cendrier pour
respecter les distances dans les zones
fumeurs un caillou qu'est ce que ça doit
rester individuelle bouteilles de gel
pour pouvoir viser à longueur de journée
et portative et également d'être anti
cauris et ensuite une une bouteille
d'eau ce mardi matin à onnaing dans le
nord l'activité a repris dans la salle
jean française du constructeur japonais
toyota
au total ce sont près de 500 salariés
volontaires qui sont venus préparer l'
usine au redémarrage partiel de la
production
1 re démarrage prévu jeudi où ils auront
cette fois ci 1200 sur site en temps
normal l'entreprise emploie 4500
personnes
nous avons des salariés qui ont des
restrictions médicales qui peuvent pas
venir
sept personnes à risque d'autres des
contraintes familiales ça représente 15%
des salariés dont 85% détails sont
disponibles
ces salariés 85% nous allons les faire
venir par rotation donc y en a deux
premiers groupes
un premier tiers qui va venir jeudi
vendredi j'ai un deuxième tiers lundi
mardi puis un troisième tiers
mercredi je bats rotation une reprise
annoncée à la suite du comité social
économique du 15 avril avec
l'approbation de l'ensemble des
syndicats à l'exception de la cgt
d'une part le flux très très content de
date lors autrement
religion de journaux en place aucune
inquiétude à avoir
je pense qu'on est beaucoup plus
sécurisée sur le sud que lorsqu'on va
faire ses courses au supermarché
aujourd'hui faire se regroupent et 4500
travailleurs dans une usine vous rendez
compte de ce que c'est ces deux fois le
porte avions charles de gaulle
sauf que nous on n'est pas en mer on est
immergé dans la population
donc la direction de toyota est là une
allée irresponsable elle prend la
responsabilité en réalité un de relancer
l'épidémie non seulement chez les
travailleurs de lusine leurs familles
sur la chaîne de production
on s'adapte pour respecter les règles
sanitaires mise en place de plexiglas
pour séparer les postes de travail et
port devises hier si les distances ne
peuvent être respectés des visières
fabriquer directement sur place pour
leur toyota prévoit une reprise de la
production à vitesse réduite
quelques centaines de voitures devraient
ainsi être produites par semaine contre
plus d'un millier par jour en temps
normal